hello and welcome to our inaugural event
the best sound short list bake off
the academy award for best sound has
gradually evolved over the last 15 years
and last year sound effects editing and
sound mixing were unified into one award
for best sound although we have unified
the award we have individual artists
that work together in unique ways to
make soundtracks that distinguish these
compelling and very diverse films
i don't want any trouble
the contrast
seemed to be amazing between the quiet
and the riot the subtle touches of
picking up the tv or constantly hearing
something like a helicopter in the
background
whatever he's experiencing even when the
film calms down and becomes an intimate
family story
you still are hearing things as buddies
gonna hear them when we got to mix it i
think what we're trying to get is this
moment of uncertainty where sound get
muffled and quiet until the moment of
the explosion
so
i was struck by the way that production
design seemed to inform the sound
product of the final mix and the choices
that you guys made what can you tell us
about your creative process and how that
worked though this is science fiction
denis wanted everything to look and feel
part of a reality that we could relate
to he really wanted things to sound as
if you had dropped a documentary film
crew on arrakis and hung out a boom pole
and captured the sounds that those
things actually made in an actual
acoustic space
make
sounds for things you've never seen
before as production design was doing
sound as if you had heard them before
the production design gave us a lot of
ideas just off the bat looking at the
screen but it also reflects denise
aesthetics so well that he's looking for
something that's grand and epic yes but
he's also looking to root it in what's
realistic what's gritty what's kind of
lived in there's always a lot of
information coming from the visuals and
coming from the production design
this is the 25th bond film i think
there's a new audience and there's also
an older audience like myself how
difficult is it to satisfy
the traditional expectations of bond
sounds
versus the new events and gadgets i
think obviously we're very mindful of
that throughout the whole process when
it comes to sort of iconic sounds that
the audience wants we look very lucky to
see in the film we have the aston
martins we have the db5 we have the va
tester martin so they're sort of what's
expected from the audience so we have
almost a tether of the films with those
sounds and then it comes to making it
modern keeping it current with the
director as well with kerry he's got his
own viewpoint so we want to make it
exciting fun but also have this sort of
history there that's going to appease
all the fans out there it is tricky and
it's something that we just have a mind
on at all times
[Music]
[Music]
when you get to the final mix there must
be some sort of sense of oh did we go
too quiet too many times was that a
major concern
in the final mix it definitely came up
um a few times where we were worried
maybe we weren't too quiet we're kind of
mixing as we goes with jane as well it's
so focused on the performances and
they're so nuanced and subtle that we
had to do the sound that way as well i
think that played such a huge part in us
being able to really strip back and and
be subtle and quiet
okay so give me the gun tony i need it
now
boy boy crazy boy
good cool boy got a rocket in your
pocket
keep cooling cool boy
don't get hot cause man you've got some
high times ahead
take it this movie was so well planned
the way it was shot the way it was
written all that kind of stuff was built
into it one of my favorite things for
sound there was a rhythm to even the
non-dance scenes that's built into the
performance and the shoot
and the choreography of of all the
action very often was timed perfectly to
what became the music and then we added
our sound effects we micro synchronized
sounds you know paint bucket hits and
pin can catches and dance moves and
everything else so it sat right in the
music
gave this movie both a naturalistic feel
to it because it's really new york but
the stylistic feeling because the rhythm
of it was so musical and precise
everything was choreographed from the
very beginning of the movie including
even dialogue scenes the soundtrack that
came out just such a beautiful rich
tapestry of new york it really is
wonderful
well we want to thank all of our
shortlist participants
and thanks to the sound branch for
showing us that best sound is so much
more than just the loudest film you've
provided us with a great slate of films
to choose our nominees from and we'll
see you at the oscars
you